[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur Papa Numéro 9 a beau se
multiplier varier les changements de
rythme appelés akeesby du geste pour lui
donner un ballon en or ça ne va plus
pour Reims
[Applaudissements]
il est vrai que les Bordelais ont une
tactique bien à eux ils se replient sur
leur coquille
[Applaudissements]
et de temps à autre c'est la
contre-attaque sèche rapide incisive
comme un trait
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme cela que les Bordelais
marquent au début
les rémois qui s'accommodent mal de
cette manière ne savent pas trouver la
parade en voici une nouvelle preuve 3-0
pour board
[Applaudissements]
c'est décourageant pour les rémois qui
se pendant vont déborder la défense
bordelaise la classe a fini toujours par
payer mais un Buré moi contre trois buts
bordelais en langage clair cela veut
dire défaite
au Palais de l'Élysée l'arbre de Noël a
poussé un peu en avant mêlée aux enfants
des collaborateurs de la présidence 200
élèves méritants des écoles de Paris ont
été les autres avis de Madame De Gaulle
et du chef de l'État qui a abandonné
quelques instants les soucis de sa
charge pour jouer les Père Noël
[Musique]
devant un auditoire spécialisé monsieur
Pisani ministre de l'Agriculture a
commenté les chances qu'offre au
cultivateurs français l'entrée en
vigueur du Marché Commun agricole
problème à l'ordre du jour pour les
différents gouvernements européens
[Musique]
le marché commun a bien entendu alimenté
la conversation du dernier week-end de
franco-anglais qui a réuni à Rambouillet
monsieur Mac Millan et le général de
Gaulle mais il fut aussi beaucoup
question de la défense occidentale qui
faisait précisément l'objet de la
session parisienne du Conseil atlantique
[Musique]
le général norstatt qui quitte le
commandement suprême à la fin de l'année
et Monsieur dinrusk auront eu la
satisfaction d'y voir leur conseil suivi
puisque les ministres des 15 ont d'un
comme un accord jugé nécessaire
d'accroître l'efficacité des forces
classiques de l'Alliance c'est là le
point essentiel d'un communiqué
optimiste
précisément ces forces classiques celles
du moins de la France et de l'Angleterre
venait de se produire sur le terrain
[Musique]
l'opération cross Chanel qui s'est
déroulée dans le sud-ouest de la France
a mis à contribution des hélicoptères
britanniques et français Nord 2501 et
astine dans une opération destinée à
traduire l'aptitude des unités à entrer
en action loin de leur base de départ
ce qui fut fait à la plus grande
satisfaction précise ton des
observateurs
[Applaudissements]
il reste que la France comme
l'Angleterre n'ont pas renoncé à leur
force de frappe nucléaire
la Royale Navy vient pour sa part de
procéder aux essais du premier
sous-marin atomique made in England pour
l'instant seul la propulsion et
nucléaire mais il est probable que
l'armement suivra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lauréate 1962 du prix Suzanne biancetti
Corinne marchand est la 20e étoile
naissante que les auteurs de films ont
choisi de couronner et leur président
chargé du discours d'usage a eu une bien
agréable tâche à remplir
[Musique]
c'est une tâche plus austère que c'était
fixé les juristes réunis à Paris par le
colloque de droit cinématographique
mettre à l'heure du marché commun le
cinéma des différents pays d'Europe qui
totalisent deux milliards de spectateurs
par an
quand Apple Émile Victor grand
spécialiste du Groenland il s'est fixé
pour tâche d'apporter l'air du pôle sur
les Champs-Élysées un certain air de
Paul tout au moins moyennant quoi le
drugstore s'est muet en campement
d'explorateurs du Grand Nord n'y a-t-il
pas que l'illusion qui compte
[Musique]
voici de nouveau Noël Noël qui donne au
plus majestueuses cathédrales comme aux
églises les plus humbles leur voix les
plus joyeux d'un goût de la chrétienté à
l'autre cette nuit-là des dizaines de
milliers de cloches et graineront leur
chandelles les graisses dans la tour sud
de Notre-Dame de Paris le célèbre
bourdon sera exceptionnellement sonné à
la volée
cette maîtresse cloche de treston qui
porte le nom d'Emmanuel arithmé les
grandes heures de la capitale
à la fin du siècle dernier a retenti
pour la première fois où sacré-cœur la
voix d'une des plus grosses cloches
connues celle de la Savoyarde 19
[Musique]
les vieux Parisiens n'ont pas oublié sa
traversée de Paris sur un char tiré par
28 chevaux entre deux haies de flambeaux
et 200 000 personnes
depuis 13 siècles les cloches ont été si
intimement mêlées au grand moment de la
vie des hommes quels ont leur art
privilège de se voir conférer le baptême
qu'elles ont une personnalité propre une
naissance une vie et une main
et un destin étrange les fait souvent
finir au lieu même où elles sont nées
les fonderies de cloches ont presque
toutes disparues l'une d'elles subsiste
encore en Normandie à l'endroit même où
elle fut créée en 1150 par l'Ordre des
Templiers
[Musique]
rien n'a changé ici dans ces moules dont
quelques-uns datent du Moyen-Âge sont
coulées dans toutes les langues les
inscriptions qui accompagneront les
cloches dans tous les pays du monde
[Musique]
comme au Moyen-Âge on atteint les vins
favorables le tirage est bon le four est
allumé
[Musique]
pour éviter qu'il n'éclate sous la
pression du métal en fusion les moules
sont enterrés dans une fosse et la terre
soigneusement tassée
la température atteint 1400 degrés
dernier instant on ajoute l'État
[Musique]
sur un signe du maître fondeur le métal
coule à flot
[Musique]
les habitants du voisinage ne manquent
jamais de venir assister à cette coulée
comme autrefois les rois les cloches
naissent toujours un public
sans le soufre et la glace calcinée
[Musique]
dans quelques jours naîtra une cloche
ternaire rugueuse LED comme un
nouveau-né avant la toilette mais demain
dans la nuit de Noël sa voix sera pure
joyeuse lorsque sonneront les douze
coups de minuit
[Musique]
mais dans le même temps où elle
appellera leurs parents à la messe la
voix des cloches d'une église
campagnarde de réveillera dans leur lit
les petits enfants du boulot
[Musique]
pour eux comme pour des millions
d'enfants ce sera le signal secret du
grand émerveillement
[Musique]
car la nuit de Noël ce sera toujours
cela le son joyeux d'une cloche une
bûche qui brûle un sapin illuminé et
tout autour les visages radieux des
enfants éblouis
[Musique]